[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
peter maurer c'est le président du
comité international de la croix rouge
qui est avec nous depuis genève merci
beaucoup monsieur marc horreur merci de
m'avoir
vous revenez tout juste d'une visite en
syrie alors 11 ans après le
déclenchement du conflit il ya eu le coc
vide maintenant il ya l'ukraine qui ont
attiré l'attention mais aussi l'argent
de la communauté internationale
quelle est la situation en syrie
la situation en syrie en général restent
extrêmement difficile parce que les
effets du conflit les destructions des
déplacements sont toujours vivants
aujourd'hui tel qu'il l'était il ya une
deux trois ou quatre années donc rien
n'a changé dans la dans l'image générale
la situation pour les personnes en syrie
les infrastructures sont détruites elles
qu'ovide a eu ses effets aussi la crise
libanaise
étroitement liée à la crise syrienne au
moins économiquement on fait que le pays
est presque dans une chute libre des
services sociaux et donc nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui à des thématiques
à des problématiques humanitaires qui
sont peut-être encore plus accentuée
qu'ils ne l'étaient pendant l'activité
militaire qu'on a connus au début de la
crise et plus intensément est ce que les
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine qu
on voit notamment la flambée des prix de
l'énergie des aliments est ce que l
frappe de plein fouet cette série qui
est déjà affaibli comme vous venez de
décrire
pour le moment je ne dirais pas parce
que beaucoup de donateurs
garde quand même
le cap et nous soutiennent aussi sur des
activités dans d'autres endroits du pays
et les budgets souvent pour cette année
était déjà approuvés j'ai plutôt craint
je crains plutôt que à long et à moyen
terme on aura peut-être des effets de
financement et puis en même temps ses
effets de financement interviendront
quand la crise des services publics en
syrie aurait encore plus accentué
davantage que ce qu'on a vu jusqu'à
maintenant donc je pense on essaye on
continue d'avoir des activités
importantes on voit la nécessité de
commencer aussi un peu une phase
nouvelle pour rétablir au moins le
minimum des services en os en santé et
d'autres services sociaux parce que à la
longue on ne peut pas traiter un pays
comme la syrie jusque dans l'urgence
avec le moteur traquer et et d'autres
formes dead qu'ils ne sont pas adéquates
aux problèmes vous avez rencontré bachar
el-assad est ce qu'il est conscient de
la situation du pays on peut imaginer
que onze ans après ils s'imaginent resté
de longues années est ce que ça change
sa perception de la situation de la en
syrie moi j'avais l'impression d'un
président qui est très conscients de
l'environnement international et des
difficultés et des pressions que cet
environnement exerce
sur sur la syrie
je dirais reconnaissant du travail des
humanitaires mais aussi très clair dans
sa vision que les choses ne peuvent pas
continuer comme ça je pense vous avez vu
que le président syrien récemment à
décréter une amnestie il faudra voir si
c'est amnesty
vraiment prend
un peu de poids ainsi si elle se réalise
en libération
de gens qui sont en détention
aujourd'hui mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est emmener en estie peut être vu
aussi comme une réponse indirecte aux
pressions que de pays tels que la syrie
et d'autres et expérimentent aujourd'hui
dans la compétition d'attention sur les
crises humanitaires à laquelle il est
confronté donc vous pensez que enfin de
vos échanges et il y a une meilleure
écoute et peut-être une certaine
flexibilité qu'il est prêt à donner
alors que jusque là évidemment c'était
niet si j'ose utilisaient le mot
nous l'espérons certainement que les
coopérations qu'on a déjà commencé
puisse s'élargir surtout dans des
populations et avec des populations et
des régions en syrie auquel on avait peu
d'accès ou pas suffisamment d'accès et
ce voyage était particulièrement
important à ce moment pour comme on dit
élargir notre surface
opérationnel dans nord-ouest en eau
reste dans d'autres régions de syrie
mais aussi par rapport à la population
disparu à la réunification de famille à
toutes les questions que la population
syrienne à porte en verre un opérateur
humanitaires comme le cicr et les gens
qui nous approchent demande de la clarté
sur leurs membres de famille j'espère
bien qu'il y aura un espace plus élargie
autant que j'espère aussi que l'espace
sera élargi pour l'assistance
humanitaire qui est tellement importante
aujourd'hui alors vous avez visités
un camp qui s'appelle alcool qui est
située dans le nord-est de la syrie les
sous contrôle des forces kurdes y vivent
plus de cinquante six mille personnes
dont deux tiers d'enfants ce sont des
familles liés directement ou pas à hadès
avant tout l'irak est née syrienne mais
aussi occidental c'est votre troisième
visite la barre quelle est la situation
dans ce camp d'al rôle monsieur maurer
moi je dirais peut-être trois choses
d'un côté j'ai été impressionné par le
travail de certaines agences
humanitaires bien sûr inclus césaire qui
a été fait pour améliorer la situation
dans les camps c'est remarquable vu
l'environnement et la situation
difficile deuxièmement c'est avec regret
aussi que je constate que malgré ces
efforts
on ne fait pas suffisamment pour avoir
un environnement qui soit acceptable
pour les populations qui sont là il est
tout simplement inacceptable que des
enfants et des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants vivent
cette dureté d'un camp au milieu du
désert n'est ce pas et qui ont tellement
c'est un environnement qui est tellement
peu favorable n'est ce pas au
développement des enfants c'est
inacceptable comme situation et
troisièmement je pense cette comme je
les dis dans d'autres occasions
c'est vraiment déplorable que la
communauté internationale malgré tous
les efforts ne fait pas suffisamment
pour apporter un
minimum de
deux d'état de droit de transparence sur
le statut de ces femmes et de ces
enfants
pas suffisamment d'efforts pour vraiment
encouragé les retours du camp à faire
des processus judiciaires sur ceux qui
sont responsables de crimes mais aussi
de libérer ce qui en fin de compte sont
maintenant détenus pendant trois ans
sans
c'est et sans
ratification judiciaire qu'ils sont
absolument nécessaires
la france est d'ailleurs un des pays qui
rapatrie le moment ses nationaux dans
des camps comme al rôle
bon moi je vais pas faire la liste
maintenant des champions et des mois
bien dans les rapatriements ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je déplore
malgré les efforts de fait qui a encore
56 millions mais milliers de gens qui
sont là bas c'est pas pour cent
d'enfants
des femmes et qui sont sans procédure
judiciaire
qui sont dans des situations difficiles
et sont vraiment un effort international
considérable pour soutenir les autorités
kurdes mais aussi et surtout pour
soutenir les retours alors je veux en
venir rapidement la situation en ukraine
vous avez été à moscou vous avez
rencontré des officiels russes notamment
le ministre sergueï lavrov miss des
affaires étrangères on voit que tous les
efforts pour créer ce qu'on appelle des
couloirs humanitaires sont extrêmement
difficile à mettre en oeuvre on parle
évidemment beaucoup de marioupol de
l'usinage opstal est ce que vous êtes
toujours aussi inquiets sur la
difficulté à faire valoir le droit
humanitaire en ukraine en ce moment
d'abord j'aimerais relever que j'ai
visités d'abord qui est fait après
moscow déjà plus de dix à six semaines
aujourd'hui je dirais deux choses n'est
ce pas d'un côté je suis un peu plus
optimiste parce qu'on a réussi quand
même pendant les dernières six semaines
de d'accomplir et de d'agrandir une
opération importante en ukraine et de
répondre aux besoins
des populations en croissant
considérablement nos services pour les
populations déplacées pour à ceux qui
sont affectés un parlait guère pour les
populations protéger inclut les détenus
les morts
et donc on est dans des
dans une situation beaucoup meilleur
aujourd'hui
d'autre part il est clair et nous le
voyons tous les jours parce que vous
nous rapporter n'est ce pas la situation
dans un conflit active reste extrêmement
difficile il ya passablement de
population qu'on a des difficultés à
atteindre qui ont des difficultés à
sortir ces négociations sont complexes
parce que la réalité sur terrain
complexe parce qu'il faut un accord des
militaires des deux côtés pour avoir une
confiance mutuelle pour avoir des
évacuations et des accès sûr je pense
vous avez vu qu'on a réussi à certains
endroits mario port souris et autres
d'accéder des populations difficilement
accessible donc on réussit des choses
n'est peut-être pas d'une manière
suffisante parce que la confiance entre
les parties n'est pas là d'une manière
suffisante pour vraiment créer des
couloirs humanitaires plus performant
est ouvert à plus sûr pour les
populations civiles est-ce que vous
pointez moscou du doigt
on pointe personne du doigt on essaie de
négocier
en diplomatie humanitaire tranquille
avec les parties pour encourager ses
couloirs et ces évacuations humanitaires
et pour faire respecter le droit pour
faire respecter le droit il faut des
fois
des mots clés et des mots clairs dans
nos discussions mais comme vous le savez
le cicr restera une organisation qui
privilège le dialogue diplomatique et
confidentiel aux déclarations fortes en
espace public peter moore je vous
remercie beaucoup d'avoir accordé cet
entretien à france 24 depuis genève et
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien
sur nos antennes restez-y pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]